next up
we could have a brand new skyscraper
coming to town
timeout reports the affirmation tower an
upside down skyscraper designed by
architect david ajay
the incredible gentleman behind the
african american history museum in dc
now it could be the second tallest
building in new york right behind one
world trade that's fascinating
more importantly it would house the
naacp and a number of minority-owned
businesses that's fantastic
the building proposal includes over 30
percent of construction going to women
and minority contractors
[Applause]
is the metaphor that like upside down is
right side up i mean they just really
want to get it right with making this
building i will say i applaud this
building but i may never go to the top
of this building did you see that it how
it's built it's literally like an upside
down okay that makes me slightly nervous
right would you go to the top of it
it's funny because when i first saw this
i was like whoa
but then hearing why and how the
building is coming out yeah
i'm it's so meaningful to me i want to
get right in it understood maybe you
convinced me i was first i was like
maybe i'll be on the first floor but
okay
take me to new heights
i couldn't agree more okay next it's
time for drew's reviews
and today we've got something super
exciting submitted by viewer kelly
fleming thank you kelly hi kelly so
apparently i just found this out too
uh music legend an american icon dolly
parton makes a mean scrambled egg i love
picturing her in the kitchen just
whipping whipping eggs it's like there's
nothing she can't do right apparently
she says that she has a trick up her
sleeve though so she makes them
uh to get them nice and fluffy she adds
a little ice water as she scrambles oh
really uh-huh do you know what else she
does she cooks them for about nine to
five minutes
[Applause]
okay i'm so excited to try dolly's
secret of pouring a little bit of ice
water as you scramble and whip
[Music]
i mean the fluff is there
it it tastes like scrambled eggs
i mean i want to be like oh my god dolly
parton you have reinvented eggs because
i love you so much but it's eggs
here's one thing that i do want to point
out
dolly has given us so much music
fluffier eggs and it's just been
reported literally today that she's
going to pay college tuition for all
dollywood employees now that
full-time part-time seasonal employees
and if you want to further your
education dolly's got you covered and i
want to say as someone who is a lifelong
dolly parton fan and i've been to
dollywood i do dolly parton you do get
infinite stars forever amen thank you
for being here
[Music]
you